problemas en el paraíso después de que
los casos de coronavirus se dispararan
en la isla de hainan hace dos semanas
los hoteles de lujo se han convertido en
centros de aislamiento a pesar de las
protestas de sus clientes
hay una protesta creo que se debe a que
11 miembros del personal han dado
positivo en la prueba de covid por lo
que la gente quiere marcharse del Hotel
pero no pueden irse el gobierno ha
puesto barricadas en el local con
estrecha vigilancia policial por el
momento
esto da mucho miedo este expatriado de
Reino Unido ha estado esperando Estas
vacaciones durante dos años pero ahora
no puede salir de su habitación el hotel
en el que estamos es muy lujoso Así que
bastante caro Así que hemos ahorrado
durante mucho tiempo para venir aquí es
devastador que no podamos ya sabes
podemos mirarlo pero no podemos tocarlo
no lo podemos tocar así que si un poco
deprimente en realidad y el ciclo se
repite caos en los aeropu y la aparición
de más hospitales de emergencia y
centros de pruebas
todas las mañanas tenemos que hacer cola
para una prueba de pcr justo al lado de
la playa este hombre es libre de salir
de la casa en la que vacaciones pero la
vida normal se ha detenido bruscamente a
su alrededor
todo está cerrado es difícil encontrar
comida y bebida
hace Solo dos meses tipo quant Estaba
encerrado en Shanghai esperaba
compensarlo con unas vacaciones en
hainan
fue un infierno puedes imaginar Así que
volver a pasar por todo eso psicológica
y físicamente es muy duro Así que mi
reacción fue encontrar la manera de
tomar un vuelo para salir de aquí
rápidamente pero la isla estuvo aislada
del mundo durante 10 días todos los
vuelos cancelados mientras vuelven a
ponerse en marcha lentamente esta
turista vuelve por fin a casa a Shanghai
una vez ahí le espera otra cuarentena
Espero que no tengamos más problemas y
aterrizamos en Shanghai a partir de ahí
nos llevarán a un hotel de cuarentena y
nos harán la prueba de pcr y si es
negativa podremos finalmente volver a
casa
en casa o de vacaciones china vive Bajo
La amenaza constante de nuevos cierres
por un pequeño número de casos todo por
una política de cero cobit